and with Speedy of the way is yanm Mark trying
to work through luk there turned over oh load
in front a shot a score that that's not asking
for a lot when you have this kind of tremendous
Talent like the Oilers have shot side of the
neck Nan Hopkins pumps it through drops for
Hyman Nifty move there around the cloud loose puck
in front all sorts of time shot the score Conor
McDavid ball trying to work away from Ryan
McLoud turned over shot score ddle is his
third even strength goal the last 14 game and
another goal the Oilers come right back and do
it again and he makes like McDavid or dry Sidle
dry Sidle shoots in turned over all in front that
should score Ryan moud again 6-3 the final the
Oilers sna that pesky three-game losing streak
they'll be at the Garden pick on the Rangers
tomorrow night Jad in the corner saucers to
paner down low CER back door save made by Skinner
he Robs a b couldn't control taken back by Conor
McDavid down the right wing boards centering pass
held up echo on the doorstep score Rangers having
to back up and part of that is as he drives in
the zone it backs up not just Keandre Miller
who does a pretty nice job here staying up on
him but Jacob trouba is deep and as he's deep
that puck slides across to Matias EOL EOL makes a
sweet little pass to Zack Heyman and there he is
on top of the blue paint posted in trying to play
two players at once it's a tough decision to make
off the draw score of Ander Kane out let lindr
pan with a reach turned back to McLoud dropped
off boogo shoot Scar and losing his balance with
Keandre Miller it's a two-on-one Fogle shoot sa
it made by quick the rebound on the doorstep score
since 1991 only the third time on consecutive days
that the Oilers have had third period comebacks
back-to- back games yesterday against the devils
and tonight against the Rangers it was a fun one
here at the Garden 43 is your final Ed able to
win it over the Rangers but Edmonson jumping on
San Jose early hman dishing off wide open McLoud
on a hot streak and he scores Ryan McLoud here's
McDavid the other way off the turnover Cent tipto
Beautiful Finish By Heyman for his 20th from the
captain grabbed by Conor Brown who stick on the
ice at home looking for a lane one timer rip oh
our in-house feed carries to the shark Tech he
was first on the end here's the dish R shot score
I it checked by burrow McDavid there Nurse to CCE
shot double to flex it through King and home for
the second time in his career steuart Skinner is
going to shut out the San Jose shks this will be
his fourth Lifetime and he's leisurely leaning
back on that crossbar having accumulated 26
saves and securing Edmonton's third straight
win and back over the 500 Mark for Chris knock's
crew 165 and one with a 5 nothing dismantling of
San Jose tonight against Vegas and against San
Jose they were down one- nothing after the first
period here's a turnover lafier swings it in
front cev Dall stopped by Skinner looks like
like they're going to do that here down low it
comes McDavid a shot and he scores this time he
put it over the right shoulder of T but middle to
the outside that's the normal setup we saw this
earlier even though he's at a bad angle he just
Heist it and he banks it off the goal tender's
head hee with a goal and assist in that first
period in 8 seconds Hunters have a power play
McDavid with it to the net Center across score
veteran Derek Ryan in round to four speeding in
on telvet shoots and scores and the Oilers win
the shootout and this the first meeting between
these division Rivals this season 3-2 is the
final coming over the line gets it back from
Fogle on a quick chance and Gibson able to
make the safe Fogle in front sh [Applause]
score
wases off one check he'll drop it for Nur
onetime Drive SLE from an impossible angle
this is a tremendous pass by Darnell nurse he
takes it to the middle and for Leon dyle he
just gets lost taken by Brown broken stick cam
Sam Carrick now five on three and a half ducks
get back to full strength as nurse finds a wide
open fog go had a broken stick and Gibson able
to weather a shot from d one timer f with short
side delivery and that line connects again Newen
Hopkins will leave it for Evan boost yard and
Anaheim wants a change here's McDavid trying
to catch the ducks in a change and he did hman
shs and scores dry will batted it down for fog
two goals two assists for Fogle tonight dry sutle
triying to one touch it in tight here's kolak and
J scores Edmonton has won seven straight in the
division five straight overall five consecutive
games on the road and are 13 and three in their
last 16 games the Oilers crawl closer to a spot
in the Wild Card they're now just three points
out with a couple of games in hand 1815 and one
with an emphatic 72 victory over the Anaheim
Ducks a perfect 3 and0 rad trip to close out
2023 Puck squs fre Newen Hopkins box is
out two on two McDavid with hman looking
McDavid to get his feet moving and adjusted
the speed you can see right here Zula going off
sanheim off maybe the toughest situation with
Conor McDavid barreling down he goes outside
inside goes back to the outside and that little
stumble by sanheim who got his feet there little
little click of the heel by himman we saw that in
the Flyers game rebounds Ry cut it back MC David
beautiful pass back score Zack what a Lo from C
McDavid Ki could not sneak it pastar one minute to
go in the period in front new Hopkins from McDavid
and the ORS regain the lead CCE the hand off to
McDavid rolls up top looking what timer Char hle
scores in that regard McDavid walks in feathers
the front reot score upstairs n Ops his second
of the night the final 10 seconds six victories
in a row for Emon the oers score the final three
goals and walk away with a 52 [Applause] Verdi
kept in by buard as Ean Hopkins took the spill
back on his feet quickly reverses Bard shoots
and scores delivered out to neutral Ice by m
and Company as Bard sends hman in the wrer and
finds the net get possession and they do Bard to
McDavid a pass down low they scor guess who it is
hatrick you know there's extending their wi
streak to seven Hyman with a hattick final
score here 3 to one when scoring first are the
most in the NHL so even when they score first
they struggle but they got a much better chance
Sanford moves in wrap around try scolling his
Skinner to pin his clove up against the Left
Post and keep the puck out of the net and now
we have our first Gathering of the night and
they did review the Sanford wraparound and the
Donado crash and did confirm no goal moving
in is ddal score moved all the way around to
Echo ahead moving in shoot score up at the far
Blue Line look at that come's taken two shoulder
checks already the Blackhawks are changing he
knows mcdavid's there and this is no chance for
Peter morazzi that pass is a bullet it's right on
the tape and in his last eight games against the
Blackhawks Conor McDavid has got seven 15 points
back to retrieve well if this tells you that the
Oilers aren't sharp tonight Heyman missed two
empty Nets here now the Hawks got a chance to
tie again Sanford and Gutman are there CC clears
The Zone 13 seconds to go pev rather Z set back
for it time for one more push Z set just fires
it all the way down it's dealt with by Skinner
puts it behind the net 3 seconds 2 one there's
blassic there's here's the horn and Edmonton
will escape with two points but they had to earn
it tonight against Chicago only 15 shots on debt
for the Oilers they couldn't find the empty net
but steuart Skinner has now one his 17th this
season and his sixth in a row I had for Kane
from to bricket Kane fabry hit the goal post
are you serious every thinks a 10 they're at
the ready with one cider kicked it ahead oh is
that too many who jumped off and who came on nice
move right in on goal what a goal you got to love
the skill and is that close to offside they're
looking at it they're going to look closely at
it I guess so here's Bard in for McDavid in
the slot for at home another wow another shot
to score left there on the change back in for
hman one and one tonight Heyman to the goal
loose Puck knocked away right back to nurse he
scores by a club record with a ninth straight
Victory there's Fogle in the corner Fogle trying
to cut to the front the N [Applause] scores
tridle back for McDavid again McDavid moving in
with it hands it off forar fire it again McDavid
moving in with it hands up B fir Stars Evan buar
the overtime winner and it's a franchise record
for the Edmonton Oilers 10 straight victories
back in plays it down to holber trying to chip
that to Matthews good stck picked off by
Matthews again walks in Fe to the CL up by
SK here's McDavid back the other way McDavid
drops that back for eckol from the high slot
two plays it back across for D side and scores
Ryan McLoud winds in drops that back on for Yan
Mark drops it back down to McLoud throws
it be but they score CeCe L Beck and shoot
plck the puck goes wide up the other side
here's McLoud walking out shoots [Applause]
SC minute 40 to play Knee Lander across Marner
and that was snatched away shot toward the empty
net skittering tumbling and into the back
of the N for the center that's picked off
by blard for the empty net and to go yes Oilers
are going to win this hockey game 11 straight for
Edmonton from the depths of 30th Place in the
National Hockey League to a team that refuses
to let this streak die for tues your final I
think it also gets the puck in deeper in the
zone which nullifies a little a little bit of
that transitional play quick snap shot St made
score waren Fogle 90% over the last couple of
months Newan Hopkins D set in front R shot save
rebound D set of scores game tied McDavid wanted
me to remind everyone what a nice kid Andre was
back then here's Dr breakway scores Ed the
ten first lead of the night Edmonson circles
back defensively at home for Kane a Vander Kane
skate the stick and now spring pass dle Fogle
scores one for three tonight dle scored it
McDavid back to stock home what a three-way
passing play McDavid now back pening deeper in the
zone for idal McDavid across they score [Applause]
zman Brown has an empty net and his shot was
deflected Away by Justin Schultz York stran
will give it back to Schultz with 15 seconds
to go the crowd recognizes Conor brown with
dearly loves to get a number up on the goal
Colum around the boards P strand a shot block
5 Seconds To Go Ryan unable to get it NW
but won't matter edans it's 112 straight
the Oilers completely shut the Kraken now
close it out and improved to 255 and one
just four points separating these two teams in
the standings here comes right CL [Applause] and
gets it to Dylan Holloway shop blocked CeCe
feeds down L Sam G out there and R into the
it's Holloway shot block CeCe just kind of chips
it down low it goes right through to Sam G he's
trying to find the slot you can see and it
goes off the stick racing to it a zachman he
gets to it hman a refer and he scores that's a
historic 13 straight victories for the Edmonton
Oilers Stuart Skinner 10th straight Victory
TR tying the franchise record set by Grant
fur way back when and the Oilers keep
piling up the points and climbing up
the standings on the left wing looking to
cut in sets it right across the slot and
scores a power play goal it'll be in Vancouver
Saturday night off the goal post rebound and
scores from the slot there's a shot down is M lein
and it's in the net board at four and a half left
now a centering pass knocked down in the slot shot
in front and scores there it is the horn to end it
a 41 final three third period goals Oilers fans
are happier as the Edmonton Oilers continue their
winning streak to 14 games here's new hkas back to
D M it a back hter score roik was still at the far
POS and whistle has it scored since November in
on picker deny doing this on the second of a back
to back again impressive they were wall up last
time here's McDavid centering tip com Zach mishes
close to one of those automatic goal situations
D tle hunts him down mcav wait shoots and scores
Edmonton has swept the season series from Chicago
a turnover a centering pass right go and a shot
blocked Pickard couldn't help himself he wanted a
little drama Newen Hopkins dry inside quick shot
score Newen Hopkins below average 76% 25th in the
league mcdavis new Hopkins cross DAV d one timer
score field that passive was broken up takes
one for M through traffic snapped it on that
save lanin juicy Rebound in front McDavid
bounces it in the effort here by McDavid
he claws through a couple national predators
gets the first shot on that Zack Hyman right
there on the doorstep McDavid comes loose
Drive SLE trying to muscle it out he does
to Hyman beautiful move around one man
to win the game Zack he does Rogers play
faithful does their job what an electric final
minute 4-1 Edmonton 16 wins in a [Applause]
row he had a guy wide open to the left of
skinners ban on this unit McDavid off the
turnover for tricyle McDavid scores the final
seconds tick off and Vegas a streak stopper
tonight on home ICE the Oilers winning streak
ends at 16 one shy of matching the Penguins